so tell tell everybody what it is what
is shift.com
shift is a way to buy and sell a car so
if you have a car to sell you come to
shift.com submit your car info we price
it for you
and then we buy from you and take it
away and if you want to buy a car you
come
find the car you'd like and then click
on a button and book a test drive and it
shows up at your house
or you can buy a car on the site itself
and then have it be shipped to you
and then it's yours and how did people
do this
how did people do this beforehand they
went to a used car a lot or they tried
to find some random stranger and get
them to meet them in a parking lot at
mcdonald's or something
yeah so the us car market in the us is
massive it's 850 billion dollars and it
split about 50 50 between
private party sales where like you and i
meet up and and sell a car to each other
which is dangerous and insane correct
but it's about 15 million transactions a
year
what 15 million cars trade hands a year
person to person
yeah and 30 million overall yep and well
30 million on top of that
is uh dealer sales half of those dealer
sales are auction sales so
this is where they sell a car to another
dealer at an auction oh
and another 15 million is sales directly
to consumer so there's a there's
close to 50 million used cars getting
sold in the united states 40 to 40 to 50
a year depending on the year
so that means i mean there's
330 million folks in america 70 million
of them will be kids
so that means like one in four adults or
one in five adults is buying a used car
a year
um so on average an american household
changes the car every three years
because on average they have more than
two cars but even if you see two cars
they kind of move through cars every six
years or so
wow and every time you buy a new car
like a brand new car something has to
happen with a used car as well right so
there's a lot of trade-ins and then
those are sold etc but
it's a it's a massive i mean cars in
general are
a huge market used cars are the largest
retail market in the us
and even though the vehicle itself has
been completely changed by technology
um even though you know how it's
configured
is very different and it's become a
computer technology hasn't really
touched the sales process
that much until about you know six seven
years ago
when shift plus a couple of companies
really started to go after it from the
digital perspective
and try to bring e-commerce to car sales
and so
is the major innovation in your model
that you buy
the cars themselves clean them up and
then have the inventory there
well dealers do that too right dealers
buy the car and then it's it's
trying to bring it online is that one
major innovation
number two is kind of putting the entire
purchase process into the control of the
consumer
so a customer can apply for financing on
their own on our website get approval
finish the transaction right that's
really easy and then thirdly the real
magic for us
is the test drive delivered to the
customer where instead of you having to
go to this
to the store are you to the dealership
to see the car the car shows up on your
doorstep
and then you can try it out and see if
you want to buy it and then you know
either buy or send it back